these girls to me all seem to want to be
the queen or the the one that everybody
think of when they say housewives I
don't think that that's possible I think
there's one queen and there's a lot of
princesses Nene thank you so much for
being here with us to co-host you were
awesome listen Real Housewives of
Atlanta airs Sunday nights on Bravo make
sure you tune in cuz you know things
will be wild Nene we love you you know
though um on Episode three we'll be
waiting for you there girl no you know
Nene we couldn't let you just come here
in co-host we had to ask you a few
questions had to put you in the hot seat
for a second oh boy alright let's start
with this you said you had one foot out
the door with the housewives but you
came back why did you come back
the first reason is this is my baby okay
I feel like I birthed this baby and I
need to see it all the way through now
there are times when I get frustrated
with it and I want to get a baby up for
adoption but you know after talking to
my family talking to my friends and my
team you know they encouraged me to go
back and pick my baby up and rock my
baby
so housewife is my baby and I really do
want to see it you know stay around for
10 15 20 years if you don't keep up with
the Joneses I am The Joneses
do you remember the very beginning I do
what do you remember about the beginning
I remember when it was just one van I
don't even know we had a van honestly we
might have been all in cars there was no
money we didn't have any they showed and
give us then if they had some we got
paid $5,000 for a whole season and that
was little you know and you know just
the way we operate now it's a hole it's
a big footprint now yeah back then it
was a thumbprint do you have any issues
with the other shows any other ladies
getting attention no I don't like being
in a sorority mm-hmm so I like a lot of
the other girls cuz we don't work
together yeah we work together then I
might not would like that Gregg is
sitting behind you yes but we saw in the
trailer that you all are discussing an
open marriage
yes you creep
and a creeper on ulema how do you feel
about open marriages so we're just
really having a and a grown up adult
conversation talking about open
marriages not that where you wanted do
you want an open marry wanted one I
would have one you would be okay with
that yeah if you wanted one but then you
be able to do your thing - absolutely
with rules
what would the rules be let's do what
you do we I don't need to see it and
then you can do what you do and you
don't need to see really long gene
putting them in each other's faces but
you know that's not what we're doing but
it was definitely a conversation that we
needed to have because I feel like if if
one or the other is being unfaithful and
you still want to be married you may as
well be having an open marriage
right I hear you're kind of open to me
but it sounds like you wanted it no
that's not the case I mean you know I
think people get it really twisted you
know Gregg has been dating me since I
was in my 20s and hit here Gregg matter
analyze circles around a young girl in
their joint ease and a lot of things
I've learned I've learned from mr. Gregg
Leakes so Gregg it's not sitting over
there like you know like in the little
angel yeah no of course I wouldn't want
to have an open marriage and if it
really got to that point I probably
would you know give Gregg the peace side
people have had things to say about our
relationship but I always it now how was
the relationship is great I mean we've
been together forever but if I'm with
way because I want to be McGrane don't
get it twisted I did not want to be
regret I would not be with Gregg and I
would tell Gregg very openly you don't
hold my tongue about stuff no you don't
however lie I'm out let's talk about
more from that trailer yes in the
trailer you told Marlo that people don't
really know the real Cynthia correct
Cynthia has a side to her that you guys
do not know about everything in the dark
yes we are talking about Cynthia Bailey
I think because I think the purpose of
that conversation was I think a lot of
people over the years have felt like I
was the more aggressive one in our
relationship or I she was following me
around or something to that effect
and that's not the case Cynthia
definitely has a side to her for
whatever reason Bravo has not shown that
side of her but that I think what is
that sign I think there's an another
side to her that isn't that kind i yes I
honestly think that she not honestly I
know that she has a side to her that is
not a kind side now that she has found
love though the inside is really who you
are it doesn't matter who you're with
you can cover it up for a little while
but that little same little person
that's gonna come out and show up at
some point and does that person show off
this season oh absolutely yes
somebody recorded you dogging her out
[ __ ]
I'm not saying that she's a bad person
I'm not saying she's not a nice person
I'm just saying that if there is a side
to her just like there would be a side
to anyone I think there's good and bad
in everybody so there is a side to her
all right let's talk about Kenya was she
the reason that you hesitated coming
back I wouldn't give her that much
credit
really absolutely how do you feel about
her now I don't have a fear what do you
mean yes what I said she is speaking
openly in the press now but very good
for her continue to speak very openly
you know she's the one who's not friends
with people she has a lie did she spit
in your face she tried to act like she
was going to spit on me and you will see
that on the show it has been rumored
that you might have a little dirt on her
marriage or you might know something
about her marriage no I'm not even
interested in her marriage I wouldn't
even care to get any dirt on her
marriage that's not who I am now she on
the other hand what might be care to get
something on me but I don't care about
her marriage I wish them well do you
think they'll get back together I don't
know and I don't care the only thing I
can say is that you know it's always sad
when a family breaks up and and I'm just
saying this over all this goes for her
as well it's is sad and it's unfortunate
that their family would break up but
that's the only thing that I have to say
about it I mean I don't care what
happened okay well let me ask you this
was it real or was it a business
arrangement I don't know what they were
what do you think they were I really
could not even think when I lay down at
night I don't have a thought of her at
all do you think that someone like
Phaedra will ever come back no maybe I'm
some sort of special they'll bring her
back but I don't ever see her back
holding a peach I love for her to be
back holding a piece but I think she's
super funny and she added a lot to the
franchise and I think that these girls
all do lowdown dirty things and so I
don't feel like you know because she's
done something that they didn't like
they have to ex her out for good we need
to end it how have you evolved with this
show and how will you be different than
the Nene we have seen from the beginning
because there have been times where you
have been the catalyst on this show it's
okay it's okay though because you know I
have to grow just like anybody else I'm
just growing in front of the cameras
you know when they found me they found
me I was much younger they're almost 13
it was 13 years ago obviously I've grown
in lots of ways which is a good thing
you know I'm almost proud of myself
sometimes I hear people say stuff and
I'd be like yeah forget it but in the
old me would be like child you can get
it it's right but now it's like forget
it
you know I've just grown in many ways in
my life a lot of things don't bother me
a lot of things I don't I don't care
about anymore I feel like I'm the show
you'll see me be quiet a lot I'm trying
in the show I actually try a lot this
season to listen to what people are
saying and then respond now I do that I
never held your tongue in your life no
but I need a job but I really did this
season I really did listen to a lot of
things that people were saying and then
I learned they weren't talking about
nothing they just talking just to be
talking it's just so stupid you know
it's just like I need to talk to Johnny
talk my man I mean really it's really
weird you know being on a show like this
because to me it's like everybody is a
large number of them feel very entitled
and it's real hard to me because when we
started it wasn't like that everybody
had their Lane everybody played their
position you know I mean these girls to
me all seem to want to be the queen or
the the one that everybody think of when
they say housewives I don't think that
that's possible I think there's one
queen and there's a lot of princesses to
the Queen well I've been here since day
one who is trying to be the queen that
is annoying you right now I can't say
anyone in particular because there are a
couple try and it's okay though they can
try they can do whatever they do I don't
own this platform you know them and I
honestly want to see the show say around
so do whatever you do because a lot of
things I'm not gonna do it's like the
evolution of Nene continues cuz now
instead of fighting folks you like let's
come together a fighter
no not a fighter but I'm saying argue
worries but you know my kid why people
mostly think that I have fought because
I can say something to make you feel
like you've been hit so I get it but you
know physically what I would say a word
and you'd be like oh gosh she hit me in
here I'm not basically you know jumping
on anybody
Hoss and among the other things you're
doing because you have done acting you
know every reality show it is Dancing
with the Stars celebrity different you
know what the celebrities with donna
tronca
celebrities like looking good do we
agree what do you think about that
coming what Donald I did not I did not
see him becoming the president I did not
see him no need to talk about it before
but I don't you talked about it to you
not to me to us to the group I didn't I
just you know somebody's just saying
that maybe run for president one day but
do you really think they're gonna
represent one day I mean I could say
that do you think I'm gonna be President
one day but you know what when I worked
with him on the show haven't I always
said this very loudly he was very cool
on the show
he liked me and I liked him and his
children were the most polite kids ever
they were very nice now ohoo his own
what we look at I don't know who he is
and what he's posted on social media I
don't know who he is I don't he wasn't
that the person that I met you're also
an ambassador for the American Cancer
Society today my husband was diagnosed
with stage 3 stage 3 a faint colon
cancer and so at that point we became
ambassadors Gregg went through a lot to
end up doing chemo he looks amazing
today he looks great well circle looks
great there's no cancer in him we did a
lot though we worked really hard for a
whole year to get Greg where he is he
looks amazing he's completely bounced
back so we want to be able to do that
for the next family so we are now
ambassadors for American Cancer Society
that is all do you also feel like a et
ambassador now anything else yes I'm
gonna eat the ambassador I also feel
like Britney Spears oops I did it oh god
you crazy
ratings
[Music]